cette chanson y'a prudemment vous parlez
beaucoup de l'expérience qu'on a eu un
migrant du liban à montréal surtout
parlé du changement qu'on a du livre
vraiment c'est comme c'est tellement
différent de s'adapter à une nouvelle
culture nouveaux pays nouvelle ville et
c'est vraiment les flics à le changement
sur nous
[Musique]
et là ces jours ci avec la pandémie on
ressent pas mal la même chose c'est
comme on sent qu'il ya un grand
changement que l'empreinte de ce père
pour tout le monde pour toute la société
les la façon dont on vit la façon dont
on voit les choses la façon dont on voit
les autres et pour nous il est vraiment
eu étrangement un parallèle entre la
chanson qu'on avait écrit sur notre
expérience des migrations et la pandémie
aujourd'hui et on a toujours un souci
aussi quand on écrit des chansons de
d'universalité donc c'est sûr que quand
la chanson avait été écrite en laisse et
ne pas être précis donc de vraiment
ouvrir sa sueur pour parler du
changement et aujourd'hui ces saveurs
c'est vraiment un sentiment qu'on se
sent à nouveau
donc c'est très actif et important pour
nous de sortir cette chanson à ce moment
là
[Musique]
deux cents
ce temps
oh
m
lentement
non
c'est donc une idée de renouveau parce
que pour vous c'est arrivé à montréal
tout était nouveau puis maintenant cette
réalité de la pandémie et nous force à
nous renouveler chaque jour suivant et
c'est aussi face à l'inconnu on sait pas
ce qu'il sent bien
[Musique]
sur nous
je voulais aussi vous savoir votre
groupe
ce duo comment s'est-il formé donc vous
êtes connu ici ou là bas comment ça se
fait qu'on a ça s'est passé n'a dit oui
au fait comme disait philippe on est
arrivé ici au début des années 2000 et
on s'est rencontré un peu après ça donc
vers 2005 2006 on était étudiant tous
les deux à méguet l'on faisait des
études pas en musique juste dans
d'autres spécialités moi je suis
biologiste il était en finance puis on a
cliqué à travers des amis il y avait une
gang des étudiants libanais en fait on
s'est tous retrouvés on se connaissait
pas au liban
on s'est rencontré à montréal et puis au
fil des années on a commencé à
collaborer ensemble à jouer ensemble de
la musique dans à différents gros donc
ça on a vraiment été très attiré par la
scène musicale montréalaise des années
2000 2010
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de groupes
indépendants ici que c'est la très très
bonne musique
donc on était dans ce c'est vraiment ont
été dans ce bain là on était vraiment
prêt on absorber tout ça on apprenait
beaucoup comment écrire la musique
comment produire de la musique on est
très influencé par les coûts des locaux
ici qu'ils allaient des studios et tout
est finalement c'était à travers une
collaboration dans des formations rock
au début surtout pouvons jouer avec un
groupe de rock au filet paiement on
l'écrivait la musique principalement et
puis vers 2015 2014 2015 2016
on s'est intéressé beaucoup plus à la
musique électronique
encore une fois grâce à la scène locale
qui est très il ya beaucoup de bonnes
musiques électroniques indépendante mais
aussi on tournait beaucoup et puis on
écoutait beaucoup ce qui se passait dans
des clubs
un peu partout dans le monde ça nous a
beaucoup inspiré et c'est à ce moment là
qu'on a décidé de partir ce duo de
producteurs plus électro mais en gardant
toutes là toutes les connaissances qu'on
en écriture de chansons en formation
rock donc sans oublier toutes les
influences qui acquit à la musique des
loyers du moyen orient que vous emmenez
avec vous en vous finalement vous savez
sûrement même pas en train de forcer
quand vous essayez de mehdi salah
dargaud demande aux pauvres aux
productions parce que c'est naturel
un chiffre
[Musique]
mais tout seul
on
c'est un besoin de communiquer parce que
c'est un langage la musique c'est un
langage qui c'est un besoin c'est
peut-être peut-être même une urgence de
communiqué j'ai l'impression
à vous entendre que vous saviez vraiment
besoin de faire ça vraiment temps que je
vous encourage à continuer celle-ci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
[Musique]